[Music]
this morning we revealed bone Appetit
magazines hot 10 its list of the ten
best new restaurants in America
number three is long oven in Richmond
Virginia which serves a tasting menu
number two is cal noodle shop in Dallas
and the number one restaurant of the
year is Combee in Los Angeles and ode to
Japan's 24-hour convenience stores the
magazine also recently revealed Dallas
as its 2019 restaurant city of the Year
well we caught up with chef Donnie Sears
the vod's owner of Cowell noodle shop
dal-su seen 10 years ago we're all about
steaks potato no big portions we took it
back to where it now it's more
farm-to-table we're trying to introduce
people to light with your food you know
understanding that this what we grew up
with our mom my grandma could to kick
this type of food for us my mom was my
influential figure in cooking she was a
stay-at-home mom cooking at home I'm
selling her dishes to friends or family
or restaurants when I was like at four
years old cooking in the kitchen with my
mom my mom was told me in order for
people to understand about it culture is
through food two or three please the
true essence of Southeast Asian cuisine
is it's making things from scratch we've
been open for ten months the first years
of the struggle a lot of customers never
experienced flushing food
our goal was to educate customers about
lotion food and our culture and also
tell them story about my mom my mom
passed eight years ago I knew that I had
to do something to pass on her legacy
and pass on our our culture I know deep
inside I know she would be very proud
that where we're at right now
we're joined now by bone Appetit
associate editor Hilary Cadogan who
spent time in Dallas reviewing some of
the top spots to grab a bite and Hillary
I have to ask you were in Dallas you
experienced this food at cow what made
it so special it's just I mean what
Donnie is doing there is just it's as
though you're like stepping into his
brain and this is what it looks like and
this is what it tastes like I mean it's
an ode to his mother who taught him how
to cook it's but it's also completely
himself he's you know experimenting with
lowchen food in a way that you know back
in his mother's generation she was not
really able to do she had to open a Thai
restaurant because she felt like you
know the American public wasn't ready
for the taste of fermented fish paste
she has to tone down what she was doing
and he's just going full force and doing
exactly you know what he can and people
are loving it what did you have there I
had everything I mean the key there is
to order the entire menu and his his
boat noodles are kind of like his thing
with blood broth in them just delicious
pork blood brah yes have you ever done a
blood broth before this I have I used to
live in Thailand so I've got your fans
I'm pretty familiar but it sounds a
little you know to the average diner it
might sound intense but it's still very
tasty it's very tasty yeah so that's
kind of his like signature dish but it's
kind of a series of different soups and
noodle dishes and then a ton of just the
key is like even if you're there by
yourself
order the whole menu and how do you go
about picking a restaurant of the year I
mean our our deputy editor Julia Kramer
is is the brains behind that operation
she spends four months traveling the
country yeah you know she comes into the
office in between and she's you know
like what can we do to make this easier
and she's you know she's amazing she
just eats at all of the restaurants and
decides which was the best one and I
think the way that she made the list
this year was really the places that she
enjoyed spending time the most like the
place that you want to hang out even
when you've got you're eating five plus
meals a day that you're like
I want to sit down and I remember this
place I want to order the next you know
I want to order dessert you know not to
be a fun job yeah when you think about
large scale restaurants and this is
something that you recently wrote about
that's not necessarily where it seems
like a lot of some of the best chefs are
going to you think large-scale you think
more money but when it comes to just
like the authentic food and just really
having sort of an intimate relationship
with those who are eating your food it
seems like smaller's where it's that
yeah it totally is cuz I feel like that
you know in that way the chef it feels
more like you're you're kind of
communing directly with the chef you
know they're it's not this ginormous you
know football-field-sized restaurant
where there's like a million people
keeping it in operation I mean some of
these cases like it's literally the chef
you know maybe a sous chef and a couple
servers and and that's that's it and and
there's something I think really
intimate and special about that when you
get to see you know you know sometimes
the kitchens right in front of you and
you watch them cooking it's got to be a
lot of hard work too though yeah for
sure
I I couldn't do it I just yeah that's
the best part what are some of the
trends that you're seeing in terms of
aside from maybe large scale and small
scale what sort of things should
consumers be looking for to kind of go
oh that's probably a good restaurant
mm-hmm
I think definitely a lean towards more
casual spots you know like we do have a
you know a tasting menu on our on our
list but I think you know the the trend
is towards like all-day cafes is a big
thing you know so it doesn't even
necessarily they're places on our list
that don't even serve dinner which is
kind of amazing when you think about the
economics of how a restaurant works
right but you know something we've got a
bakery on there you know we've got a
taco truck I think it's you know casual
spots that people just want to sit you
know life's hard the world's difficult
place just someplace you want to sit and
eat and spend time and enjoy yourself I
think is kind of the key and just
delicious foods so we're seeing like a
lot of you know second-generation chefs
to who are cooking the food that they
grew up eating and also getting a chance
to experiment
with it as well so I think yeah those
are some of the trends that I'm excited
about when you when you think about
Dallas and I think most people think
Dallas they're not necessarily thinking
of some of the experiences that you've
had helped us understand why what sort
of puts Dallas on the map yeah so I mean
I was actually born in Dallas it hadn't
been back in many years but you know
when I went there I was kind of blown
away because I think you know the other
Austin and Houston are sort of the
cities you think of when you think of
food in Texas it's never Dallas but you
know I know when Julia was there she was
like wow I felt like I there are all
these I thought about big fancy steak
houses and like that and then actually a
very diverse totally it's very diverse
it's a city of neighborhoods you know
there's there's a Chinatown there's a
you know Indian neighborhood there's you
know I mean I found like Middle Eastern
stretchy ice cream that was delicious
and you know an Iraqi Baker doing this
incredible bread and you know there's a
huge lowchen population which you know
Donnie's restaurant is not the only
lation restaurant there I mean there's
just I was just so impressed by all of
this you know people are just they're
having fun and developing their own
community of restaurants I mean Petra
and the Beast was another big one misty
Norris is doing these crazy things with
charcuterie she's got this plate called
me Tom's that's you know you might find
a milk bathed chicken heart on there you
might find you know but yeah it's just
really exciting what is going on and
it's small restaurants and it's chefs
just going for their own passion which
is really cool to see of course the
focus is the food but what can you tell
us about some of the beverages that oh
variants dollars oh there was some good
beverages I'm a big best gal fan so I
actually spoke with Bryan Reinhardt he's
the food critic at the Dallas Observer
so he was kind of like my local guide
where I was like I gave him my list of
places to check out I was like okay
which of these places do actually need
to go and he was like here here and here
and he was like also you check out the
muscala scene there's several different
bars serving you know it's an agave be a
spirit from Mexico and you know there's
encyclopedic menus you get you go there
and you just tell the bartender yeah
exactly because there's all different
types of agave plant and so that was
really exciting I did kind of a tour of
tour of mezcal bars and then you know
there's just a lot of exciting cocktails
happening there - like I stayed at the
jewel hotel and right downstairs is the
Midnight Rambler which is this really
fun bar that's kind of based off of the
bar from The Shining the movie okay it's
not as creepy as that so funny cuz I'm
always usually trying to stay at Hilton
brand hotel yeah Alice I might have to
check this thing yeah check out the
jewel inside of it yeah at a Dallas the
next time yeah well first I want to
showcase the lovely bone Appetit
magazine which is right here you guys
have a lot of helpful information in
here but there's something special
happening in New York City that you guys
wanted to discuss where you can actually
get a taste of everything well from the
the top ten mm-hmm
chefs in one place yes on October 19th
we've got our hot ten party it's gonna
be the biggest one we've ever done we do
it every year but you know it's kind of
a funny process because you know these
chefs who are on the top ten did not
find out they were on the top ten until
this morning
and then we were like okay so also we're
gonna need you to come to Brooklyn in a
month and just cook up a big feast for
3,000 people and they're like okay cool
so and that that what's happening at ER
day October 1819 night yeah you can get
your tickets we're at be a hot 10.com
okay and how much are they they are I
think believe they start at 199 but you
but it's drinks unlimited food unlimited
drinks all the be a Test Kitchen editors
who are you know big celebrities now
there won't be this our whole editorial
staff behind the scenes people will all
be there too
so don't forget you get all your
information right here on bone Appetit
yep Hillary Cadogan thank you so much
thank you so much again and talking to
us and I look forward to checking out
that event
yes I'm bored of seeing you there all
right to learn more about the
restaurants featured in bone Appetit
restaurant city of the year just head to
bone Appetit comm can also find the link
to that on our website CBS news
calm
[Music]